[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Mitri Serien schönen guten Abend
zusammen der feiertagssport heute wieder
mit Katja Stresow ich freue mich schönen
guten Abend und wahrscheinlich können
sie sich denken womit unser Themen
Überblick heute beginnt
Einheitsfeierlichkeiten in schweren
Zeiten beim Festakt den Erfurt
beschwören Politiker den Zusammenhalt
der Wendezeit
der Medizin-Nobelpreis geht nach Leipzig
ein schwedischer forscher vom
Max-Planck-Institut wird für seine
Arbeit zur menschlichen Evolution
ausgezeichnet
und Oktoberfest Bilanz weniger Besucher
weniger Bier aber stark steigende
corona-infektionen
[Musik]
32 Jahre deutsche Einheit natürlich
spürt man an Tagen wie diesen auch immer
der Seelenlage der Nation nach das ist
heute nicht anders was aber anders ist
sind die vielen gleichzeitigen Krisen
die wir gerade durchleben weswegen beim
Festakt in Erfurt Einheit auch besonders
beschworen wurde anderswo wie in Gera
nicht so sehr dort wurde demonstriert
Melanie Haack fasst den Tag zusammen
drei Tage Bürgerfest in Erfurt rund
100.000 Menschen sind gekommen
zusammenwachsen ist das Motto der
Einheitsfeiern 32 Jahre wiedervereint
ein Grund zum Feiern
es ist jetzt eine schwierige Zeit
gekommen irgendwie es gibt ein bisschen
zur Seite Deutschland ist eins und
eigentlich geht es in allen fast besser
und würde ich so sehen bin stolz darauf
dass wir wieder zusammengefunden haben
dass die Regierung das geschafft hat
aber auch jetzt langsam mit Sorge weil
es jetzt überall so Berg abgeht beim
zentralen Festakt im Erfurter Theater
betont Bundestagspräsidentin Bars die
Stärke der deutschen Demokratie und
benennt gleichzeitig die Unsicherheiten
durch den Krieg in der Ukraine und die
Energiekrise in Deutschland vor allem
die schwächsten müssen wir schützen
nicht alle brauchen Entlastung aber alle
brauchen eine Chance auf Teilhabe in
unserer Demokratie
die deutsche Einheit ein Prozess mit
Spannungen auch heute noch so der
Gastgeber Thüringens Ministerpräsident
ramello das hat auch mit Verletzungen
und Enttäuschungen und
Missverständnissen auf beiden Seiten zu
tun die viel zu selten in den Blick
genommen werden und wir brauchen viel
häufiger konkrete Ideen wie wir zu einem
miteinander auf Augenhöhe kommen können
zur Stunde wird im thüringischen Gera
wieder demonstriert 4000 Menschen gegen
die Politik gegen Deutschlands Verbleib
in der NATO für Russland rechtsradikale
Gruppierungen hatten dazu aufgerufen
bewusst am dritten Oktober
Einheitsfeiern in Zeiten der Krise die
zeigen die Arbeit an der Einheit bleibt
auf vielen Ebenen
[Musik]
in Moskau heute ein weiterer Schritt zur
völkerrechtswidrigen Übernahme von vier
ukrainischen Gebieten die Duma das
russische Unterhaus hat die
annexionsverträge ratifiziert zugleich
versuchen ukrainische Truppen im Osten
ihres Landes weitere von Russen besetzte
Gebiete zurückzuerobern in der südlichen
Region herson brachten ukrainische
Einheiten zwei Ortschaften wieder unter
ihre Kontrolle
bei der Präsidentschaftswahl in
Brasilien hat Herausforderer und
Ex-Präsident Lula da Silva zwar gewonnen
trotzdem kann er sich nicht als Sieger
fühlen mit
48,4 Prozent blieb Lula knapp hinter
manchen Umfragen die ihn über 50 gesehen
hatten abendsinhaber bolsonaro erreichte
mit
43,2% dagegen deutlich mehr als
prophezeit jetzt müssen beide Ende
Oktober in die Stichwahl und das könnte
noch mal richtig spannend werden
Christoph röckerath aus Rio
fast schon trotzig halten sie Fackeln in
Rios Nachthimmel die Anhänger von
Ex-Präsident Lula haben vergeblich
darauf gebaut dass ihr Kandidat schon in
der ersten Runde die absolute Mehrheit
holen würde ich bin sehr traurig ich
hatte gehofft dass er am ersten Wahlgang
gewinnt ich könnte heulen aber gut
morgen ist er neuer Tag
die Umfragen hatten einen Vorsprung
Lulas von rund zehn Prozentpunkten auf
bolzenaru vorhergesagt am Ende aber
liegen sie viel näher beieinander
Herausforderer Lula gibt sich nun erst
recht kämpferisch
wir werden diese Wahl gewinnen was wir
hier erleben ist nur eine Verlängerung
für uns
Präsident bolsonaro geht unerwartet
gestärkt aus der Wahl hervor auch seine
Partei konnte zulegen auf Landes- und
Bundesebene für ihn gilt es nun die
unentschlossenen zu gewinnen und so gibt
er sich ungewohnt versöhnlich
wir werden mit Nachdruck den Menschen
zeigen dass wir verstanden haben dass es
einigen wirtschaftlich schlechter geht
aber die Wirtschaft erholt sich gut der
erste Wahlgang hat die Spaltung
Brasiliens verstärkt zwar hat der linke
Kandidat Lula wie erwartet gewonnen doch
auch das rechte Lager um Präsident
bolsonaro konnte auf allen Ebenen
deutlich zulegen selbst wenn Lula die
Stichwahl gewinnen sollte dürfte das
Regieren bei so viel Gegenwind schwierig
werden zumal die wiederholten
Behauptungen wohl zu Naros bei der Wahl
würde betrogen sollte er verlieren bei
vielen seiner Anhänger offenbar
verfangen die zeigen sich trotz der
unerwarteten Zugewinne enttäuscht
es gab auf jeden Fall betrug
in vier Wochen werden die Brasilianer in
der Stichwahl entscheiden wer ihr
nächster Präsident sein wird
von Brasilien nach Iran wofür mehr
Freiheit gekämpft wird nach dem Tod von
Marsa Amini rollt eine Protestwelle
durchs Land sie starb in Haft von der
Sittenpolizei festgenommen wegen ihres
angeblich ohne islamischen Outfits Irans
oberster Führer Carmen nee spricht von
Krawallen hinter denen die USA und
Israel steckten Außenministerin baerbock
kritisiert die so wörtlich rohe Gewalt
des Regimes Lück wahlport berichtet
Freiheit so die sprechöre der
Studentinnen und Studenten heute in
Isfahan wir sind das Volk riefen sie in
Teheran trotz der erheblichen Gefahr
protestieren weiter tausende gegen das
Regime die Sicherheitskräfte reagieren
mit immer größerer Brutalität
Menschenrechtsgruppen sprechen von mehr
als 50 Toten bislang darunter Frauen und
Kinder Irans Machthaber hamminé zeigte
sich demonstrativ umgeben von
bewaffneten heute in seiner
Stellungnahme zu den Protesten nannte er
den Tod der 22-jährigen einen
schmerzlichen Zwischenfall zu den
Umständen kein Wort stattdessen die
üblichen Schuldzuweisungen
diese Unruhen wurden alle von Amerika
und Israel geplant und von den
iranischen Verrätern im Ausland
die Demonstranten so Harmonie sei nur
eine kleine Gruppe von Jugendlichen die
werde man bald schon disziplinieren
gestern abend hatten Polizei und
bewaffnete Milizen in der
sharif-universität in Teheran mehr als
100 Studierende darunter auch einige
Professoren eingekesselt gejagt und
verprügelt es gab viele Festnahmen die
Uni ist seither geschlossen
nach der Massenpanik in einem Stadion im
indonesischen Malang herrschen Wut und
Trauer der Polizeichef wurde entlassen
Angehörige der Opfer sollen entschädigt
werden am Samstag war es nach einem
Spiel zu einer der schlimmsten
stadionkatastrophen in der Geschichte
des Fußballs gekommen 125 Menschen
starben unter ihnen 32 Kinder mehr als
300 Menschen wurden verletzt
wie der Papa so der Sohn schon sein
Vater hatte
1982 den Medizin-Nobelpreis bekommen und
genau die Auszeichnung erhält jetzt auch
der in Leipzig forschende Schwede Svante
päpo Verwandtschaft ist es überhaupt
sein Thema pepo erforscht die
biologische Entwicklung des Menschen und
hat als erster das Erbgut des
Neandertalers entschlüsselt das Ergebnis
jeder von uns trägt etwa zwei Prozent
vom Neandertaler in sich was die
Erkenntnis auch für die Medizin bringt
dazu Christina kayatz
strahlend betritt swante päwo sein
Institut in Leipzig seit Jahrzehnten
widmet er sich den uralten Knochen der
Neandertaler ein Forschungsvorhaben das
vielen zunächst eher kurios erschienen
angefangen als seine Liebhaberei oder
eine Art Hobby
vor 30 Jahren und wurde ziemlich lange
angesehen als irgendwie ein kurioser und
ich denke dass es ist jetzt so ein
bisschen angekommen aus sein ernste
Forschungsrichtung mit viele
Gruppenarbeiten
ein bisschen angekommen in der Welt der
Forschung eine höfliche Untertreibung
denn eine höhere Auszeichnung als der
Nobelpreis ist nicht denkbar inzwischen
hat swante perbo nicht nur viele
Geheimnisse der Neandertaler gelüftet er
erkannte auch wie sich das Erbgut von
Neandertalern und modernen Menschen
durchmischte und dies jeden von uns in
unterschiedlicher Weise beeinflusst es
gibt Sachen die heutzutage so schlecht
sind sagen wir wie ernst man erkrankt
wenn man mit von kovic infiziert wird
von dem Virus da ist es ein Risikofaktor
der von den neandertage kommt es gibt
aber andere genetische Varianten die uns
schützen zum Beispiel besonders
eine Beispiel ist in der Schwangerschaft
gegen
Fehlgeburten früher Schwangerschaft da
ist eine gute Sache
das Neandertaler Genom kann der modernen
Medizin also wichtige Hinweise geben
dies aber ist eher ein glücklicher
Zufall als Absicht denn zunächst war es
nur Neugier die swante pepo zu seiner
Arbeit trieb
weniger Besucher weniger Bier dafür
entspannt und gut gelaunt das ist das
Fazit zum Münchner Oktoberfest das heute
zu Ende geht
5,7 Millionen Besucher verzeichnen die
Veranstalter eine halbe Million weniger
als bei der letzten Wiesn 2019
sprunghaft nach oben ging es dagegen mit
den corona-zahlen die Inzidenz die lag
am Freitag bei fast 800 das ist fast
viermal so viel wie zu Beginn der Wiesen
Svenja bergerhoff mit den Einzelheiten
am letzten Tag gibt es ihn doch noch mal
den weiß-blauen Himmel über der Münchner
Theresienwiese denn schlechtes Wetter
hat dieses Jahr die Wiesn bisher
dominiert und gerade den Schaustellern
das Geschäft verhagelt trotzdem der
wiesn-chef ist zufrieden die Wiesen sie
ist wieder da und das ist eigentlich die
Kernbotschaft und 5,7 Millionen Gäste
haben den Weg auf die Wiesen gefunden
und ich glaube dass diejenigen die allen
Widrigkeiten zum Trotz ihren Spaß haben
wollten und ihre Freiheit auf der wiesen
sie auch bekommen haben in den
Festzelten spürte man kaum einen
Unterschied zu 2019 ausgelassen wurde
gefeiert gesungen und Bier getrunken
insgesamt schenkten die Wirte 5,6
Millionen Mass aus dass das Coronavirus
in den Festzelten optimale Bedingung
vorgefunden hat ist kaum eine
Überraschung unter den Bediensteten hat
es allerdings nicht die befürchteten
Ausfälle gegeben auch wenn sich die
Inzidenz in München seit Beginn der
Wiesen ungefähr vervierfacht hat seit
wir alle Menschen oder zumindest die
Menschen die gefährdet sind dreifach
geimpft haben hat die sogenannte
fatalitätsrate die Rate derer die schwer
erkrankt und die Rate derer die sterben
einfach deutlich abgenommen das ist ein
dramatischer Unterschied zu dem was wir
vor zwei Jahren hatten mit einer
gewissen Gelassenheit schaut man in
Bayern also zumindest noch auf die
corona-zahlen und feiert heute erstmal
friedlich und fröhlich das Ende des 187
Oktoberfest
jetzt der Sportkarte wir starten in eine
Fußball Champions League Woche genau
morgen Abend spielen die Eintracht
Leverkusen und die Bayern letztgenannte
allerdings ohne Joshua Kimmich und
Thomas Müller die positiv auf das
Coronavirus getestet wurden aber auch
ohne die beiden sind die Bayern klarer
Favorit gegen Viktoria Pilsen
für Trainer nagelsmann und sein Team
sind die Tschechen aus Pilsen in dieser
Woche offenbar nur der zweitwichtigste
Gegner von dem es ist extrem wichtig für
die Champions League dieses Spiel zu
gewinnen gegen Pilsen und natürlich auch
wichtig den Rhythmus zu behalten für
Dortmund in der Bundesliga sind wir
wahrscheinlich noch ein bisschen mehr
unter Druck als in der Champions League
am Freitag wurde die bayerische
Minikrise beim 4:0 gegen Leverkusen nach
Toren unter anderem von Jamal musiala
und vom seit Wochen erfolglosen sadio
mané zu den Akten gelegt gegen Pilsen in
der Startelf vertraut der Trainer auch
Hund gerade auf die fußballkünste von
Serge gnabry ich glaube ich bin schon
ein Trainer oder ein Trainertyp der ihm
sehr viel Vertrauen geschenkt hat schon
immer in Hoffenheim schon und jetzt auch
und demnach Kanada sehr befreit auch
Spielen gegen Viktoria Pilsen könnte
sich das Spiel der Münchner morgen Abend
einmal mehr rund um den neuen
bayerischen Schlüsselspieler Jamal
musiala drehen
bei der tischtennis-mannschaft WM China
haben die deutschen Frauen souverän als
Gruppenerste das Achtelfinale erreicht
und auch Deutschlands Männer sind auf
dem besten Weg in die nächste Runde dank
eines drei zu eins über das französische
Team
Heinzel Europameister dank Q im
Hintergrund kommt zu zwei Siegen beim
Erfolge bei Frankreich gegen die Brüder
Felix und hier Alex hildebrand hat er
wenig Mühe das deutsche Team kann das
Vorrunden aus abwenden vor dem
abschließenden Spiel gegen Außenseiter
Usbekistan sind die Chancen gut die
Ko-Runde der Team-WM in China zu
erreichen
der nach der Niederlage gegen Indien
überraschend ins Team gerückte
19-Jährige Kai stumper von Borussia
Düsseldorf hinten im Bild steuert mit
seinem Sieg gegen den früheren
Europameister Emanuel den dritten Team
Punkt zum Sieg bei ja morgen Usbekistan
und dann das Achtelfinale Dankeschön
Katja und wir hätten noch diese
Wetteraussichten
im Norden und Osten teils dicht bewölkt
sonst nach Nebelauflösung eine
freundliche Mischung aus Sonne und
Wolken bei 15 bis 20 Grad in den
nächsten Tagen dann noch viel Sonne und
mildere Temperaturen schalten Sie gerne
ein um 21 Uhr das heute journal mit
Marietta Slomka schönen Dank Ihnen noch
einen entspannten Abend und bis morgen
[Musik]